So, I think in the future,
there's going to be a faster and faster
pace of technology
and how humans interact with technology
will really be a crucial thing.
I think there's a certain rate
at which us humans can adapt to technology,
and there might be a niche for somebody
who can help us transition
to the different changes in technology,
so more like a personalized technologist,
you know, assistant,
that can help us transition
from one technology to the other
as we pursue our own individual lifestyles.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.